and a good monday evening to you thanks
for joining us on eight news now at five
i'm brian loftis and i'm denise feldas
some local consumer news here at five
used cars are really in high demand so
that means the prices are going way up
that's right and according to the very
latest data coming out of the labor
department they have increased by more
than 40 percent also adding to the issue
local dealerships experiencing a delay
in new car shipments joe mohler is live
at findlay toyota in henderson with the
impact on your wallet joe
i'm brian denise whether you're buying a
new car or a used car it will be no easy
task right now just take a look at this
empty lot here at findlay toyota this is
a site you might see at many dealerships
around the valley
pandemic related shortages are
continuing to impact the car industry
people can't get the new car they want
so they opt for a used one that is
causing prices to go up ground stock
doesn't exist for us we ran out of new
cars john barr general manager at
findlay toyota says it's been
challenging to navigate with the
shortage which means less cars are
getting built
people still obviously are in the market
to purchase the vehicle so what happens
is the used car pricing is gone and it's
escalated way way out var says despite
the pandemic sales are up right now they
have around 900 pre-ordered cars and
could take a vehicle a month or two to
come in
back out here live you're taking a look
across the street from findlay toyota at
the lexus dealership over here another
empty lot there now barr says if you
were looking to possibly trade in your
car you have now you could be getting a
better deal now than you would let's say
a year ago but the issue then is finding
the other car you want reporting live in
henderson this evening joe muller live
local now